plaidoyer donc on va faire du sport tout
le week-end et on va terminer cette
cette page spéciale par l'allemagne qui
a souvent été montré comme un modèle en
la matière école le matin sport
facultatif et gratuit l'après midi tout
serait parfait si certains enfants ne
trouvait pas les journées précisément un
peu trop chargé à berlin un reportage de
notre correspondant bruno elle d'un
merci gens te paie 1 au stade olympique
de berlin la flamme brûle pour les
meilleurs sportifs des écoles allemandes
quelques faux départs c'est l'émotion
sans doute chaque mois de septembre la
grande finale par équipe rassemble ici
près de 3000 élèves et leurs profs de
gym la crème des trois cent mille
athlètes qui pratiquent dans les
associations sportives des collèges
fédéraux le système fonctionne mais
aujourd'hui difficile de convaincre les
jeunes de chaussée des baskets
le sport n'est plus et de loin
l'occupation numéro un du temps libre je
crois pourtant que beaucoup d'enfants
aimerait faire du sport mais pas
nécessairement dans une structure comme
un club le matin berne soumet ses élèves
à l'emploi du temps trois heures de gym
obligatoire par semaine l'après midi en
revanche ils entraînent des équipes de
football féminin ces élèves ne paie pas
un sou et sont toutes volontaires mais
certaines pourtant assidus trouve de
rythme un peu stressant j'ai l'école les
devoirs à faire quand je rentre ensuite
à l'entraînement trois fois par semaine
tout ça c'est un peu beaucoup à la
mi-temps à l'heure des comptes l'équipe
mène 2 0 plutôt encourageant mais berne
se dit qu'il faudra bientôt trouver de
nouvelles motivations pour attirer les
élèves sur son terrain je pense que tout
dépend de notre capacité à rester à
l'écouté des tendances actuelles il faut
tenir compte de tout ce qui a trait à la
mode à l'habillement à tous les
accessoires pour les jeunes se la joue
un rôle extrêmement important
peut-être mais la clé du succès du sport
scolaire reste ici la journée continue
qui libère les élèves l'après-midi sans
parler des résultats obtenus dans
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est ce sont
les meilleurs parce qu'on donnait plus
d'importance aux sports mais il avait
des écoles spéciales des lycées sportifs
ou les meilleurs élèves
même région étaient rassemblés il y à de
bons résultats mais ils ne doivent pas
dissimuler la réalité en allemagne pas
plus qu'ailleurs l'école ne prépare aux
sports de haute compétition des
champions ness ailleurs dans les clubs
voilà